So the super in supercomputing
is about solving big,
hairy computational problems
as efficiently as possible.
And here at Georgia Tech, there are many
examples of scientists everyday
using supercomputers to do
all kinds of important stuff.
Stuff like simulating
the dynamics of the earth, or
studying biomolecular systems.
Or analyzing social networks,
or understanding the cosmos,
just to name a few.
Now, these are incredibly
complex phenomena and
many scientists believe we won't
gain any insight into them without
some combination of your mathematical
models, leaner algorithms and
data structures, more and accurate data,
as well as enough processing color.
Now ours is a CS course
on super computing.
So the main question we'll be interested
in is, given a computational problem and
a machine, how do you compute at
the absolute limits of scale and speed.
You'll encounter many such
limits throughout the course.
But one of the more interesting ones,
come from physics.
These are things like limits
based on the speed of light,
all the amount of energy, power or
heat dissipated by the system.
In fact that's the reason we're here
in this crazy mad scientist lab
run by my crazy mad scientist friend and
colleague Ken Brown.
Ken Brown and
his crew are thinking about how to
build Quantum Computing Systems.
That represents one of the ultimate
limits of physical computation.
Now we won't actually talk about quantum
computing stuff in this class, but
I wanted to start there to sort
of stimulate your imagination,
not only about the limits of
conventional computing systems but
also about what might lie beyond.